this episode of star talk is brought to
you by curiosity stream hey YouTube
averse Neil deGrasse Tyson here coming
up is an episode of star talk where we
tackle the science of pop fiction this
is Startalk I'm your host Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist and
this is a cosmic queries edition on
science in pop fiction what does that
mean I got my resident geek in chief
with me
Charles Lou Charles welcome back to
Startalk
what if you're like such a regular on
the show because there's certain
categories of expertise that you just
plug that hole and we just sit back and
enjoy I live to serve thank you for
having there you go Chuck nice that's
right as always dude that's right always
pleasure to be here man all right so you
got wheat solicited questions we have
sliders in coop thicken pop fix and so
it's my vision for television you know
maybe comedy so it could be superheroes
superhero sci-fi sci-fi fantasy right
all of the above whatever is putting
science in there fiction we're gonna
talk that's right okay that's right I
think of pop fiction as the kind of
fiction that you would watch while
eating popcorn okay pretty much anything
else
pop all right that's a Chuck what do you
have all right you'd call me Charles if
you'd like and you can call me Chuck
yeah with interchangeable but you were
Chuck in college Yeah right yes you were
chucking coke I'm still Chuck now by the
way I was truck in high school awesome
yes I was yeah how were you chuck in
high school I hung out with a couple of
friends who noticed that I was always
jovial a night peppermint patty was it
was they noticed that that I chuckled a
lot and so they had their own own
nickname for me that no one else had and
it was Chuck which was short for
chuckles and that ended after high
school all right cool stop laughing but
no one really cares right and then you
became dr. Hibbert do we really have
three Chuck with Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck
it's mm-hmm how much
with a woodchuck chuck alright here we
go this we always start with a patreon
patron because they support us
financially and we're horse so I this is
from this is from Mike Walter it on
patreon and this what he says horan
shows like the orville and many others
they often communicate with people
light-years away they never explain how
they do it maybe there's a wire that
passes through a tiny wormhole to
connect earth what I'm wondering though
is if they were able to reliably share
the same sense of time for the duration
of their conversation with one of
themself like a chipmunk and the other
sound like they're in slow motion what
other weird effects might occur too
great a really great question you know
we're so distracted by well that
wouldn't make noise in the vacuum of
space right this book person thinking
deep yes he is about conversations we
have this issue with communicating with
the Mars rover right the Mars rover
what's the delay on the Mars on average
about 20 minutes so is it so yeah hello
watch out for the cliff and it's too
late for the cliff the rover's all have
some kind of AI on them to know where
they're headed in and how dangerous it
might be right well this is what command
we give them yeah you cuz we're it's
like being it's like having a lousy
parent playground so okay so clearly
they're communicating with people much
farther away than just earth to Mars
right so I'm thinking it's got to be
some wormhole channel Charles you got a
good opinion about that in Star Trek
specifically there is this construct
called subspace yeah which transcends a
regular space and time and basically
anything that happens in subspace you
can just assume works just as if you and
I were next-door to each other or in the
same room in real time yes but that
completely doesn't affect the entire
rest of space and time it's really a
very fun entertaining convenient
construct it be cool if that were the
thing right right it would and perhaps
someday that will be but if that were
the case so
so for Eisen FiOS eat your heart out the
the problem of course is that if you can
have this transluminal communication you
really mess up causality you can really
have an issue like let's say I somehow I
magically able to tell that Mars rover
watch out for the cliff in instantaneous
time and then the rest of the signal
where somebody else is watching that
rover it takes 20 minutes for us to see
that that rover avoided the cliff and so
you're really turning into a strange
opportunity to twist what's causing what
who's causing things and and all of
physics starts to break down under those
circumstances so superluminal
communication or faster-than-light
communication right is approximately as
challenging as faster than light travel
to our ability to understand how physics
works and in fact this is just the
movement of information yeah has
tremendous consequences very very not
done according to the universe in which
we have laid down our laws of physics
right but the is there a coherent set of
laws of physics that will allow
superluminal communication and not mess
things up at the moment no so let's say
if we're waiting for someone else to be
born all right take it to the next step
right yeah well so the comments about
whether or not you sound like a chipmunk
or you talk really slowly is at low
frequency yes that's right
the idea is no my favorite scene ever
was in was in in what's that Riding Hood
movie Little Red Riding Hood movie good
wait in the wings Third Way it's a
chipmunk no one understood the chipmunk
and you just think about to be in a cute
little chipmunk right and then the
detective says I think I know what's
going on here
it Ward's the chipmunk and inflation it
says I was witnessed
deliberate low frequency voice heads
translating the the chipmunk but right
so that kind of effect is what we called
the Doppler effect right especially the
Doppler effect for sound and Neil you
and I understand that very well just
when we're out on the streets in New
York and the ambulance goes by or
something like that well they go back
too slowly to have any Doppler effect
yeah well in New York they do every time
I see an ambulance in New York I'm like
that guy's dead
it's like sitting at a light for 20
minutes and it's trapped on the street
it's just all right sorry good you need
a drones to carry these folks all right
so if you're going through a wormhole
you're not having these Doppler effect
so you're not gonna different dining
there anything if you're close to a
black hole sort of like in the movie
interstellar you do have things change
in terms of light and sound and those
kinds of things but in order to to
really predict what's happening in terms
of sub superluminal communications I
think we are well beyond normal science
as we understand it now and like the
Orval we're totally in fiction okay all
right all right all right that's right
what a great question man way to go all
right let's go to Chris Mangrum from
Facebook so we're done with the patreon
yeah right now okay we'll get back to
you no I don't want to I don't be that
much dinner first
here we go
this is Chris mangram from Facebook who
says have you ever watched a superhero
sci-fi movie that hadn't made you cringe
and if so what was it I think that let's
frame that positively is there a
superheroes or sci-fi movie that you
have watched and appreciated the amount
of science that was built in and the the
level of science accuracy that's really
what this I think what you just put
apart
put a positive in a positive frame year
let's trade off your okay give me a
movie and I'll give you a movie I will
just and we'll go down the list okay
until week until we cry all right
in terms of movies superhero movies that
maybe we can do like how long did it
take before I started to cringe or
something like that okay the movie that
made me cringe least least it was
interesting the 1966 Batman movie the
original no no no not that's the one we
had shark repellent and they're
identical to each other except to
speaking each other's right which by the
way is almost as believable as the Tower
of Babel anyway go ahead okay you said
night I did not cringe at that one is to
be where we're waiting when what
fraction of our audience even have seen
that movie well you didn't ask me like
80 years olds we've seen now no like
that I know that on college campuses on
many college campuses as the annual
watching of the Batman gotcha
okay so I do believe that man stole my
Walker so much so my cringing yeah was
okay I even allowed there to have been
shark repellent in a spray can yes this
is prima there was Batman to repellent
and there was no repellent whatever was
here's my thing my issue was how big is
his utility belt to just always happen
to have shark repellent he didn't have
the bat shark repellent on him at that
time it was in the vehicle it was in the
back copter and that shark was attached
to the Batman's leg as he was coming up
on the rope ladder and he said quick
Robin hand me the bat shark leash Helen
so from the cabinet that had the bat
shark repellent that manta ray repellent
bat whatever that kind of like a spice
rack of the poetess
and he grabbed the thing and sprayed it
and then they would fell down and then
explode I thought it came from no so the
reason it wasn't cringe-worthy for me is
because I knew that it was totally can
be free to begin with right okay in a
sense I prefer movies of that genre that
don't take themselves too seriously like
Mars Attacks yes if there operably
messed up then I don't really worry too
much about how they what bothers me it
really marks the element yeah the the
aliens you say and they were destroyed
only by boat should we spoil the movie I
don't know let's not spoil the movie but
it turns out something weird about link
Mars Attacks yes something completely
unexpected saves the world now the kids
have something to go look mars open so
in that vein right my movie where I just
said okay I am leaving all realities
ending all this attack of the killer
tomatoes yes so the tomatoes just
jumping and smothering vehicles and I
said okay okay I'll give it to them
alright and only regret is I still don't
know if you're a fruit all right same
kind of genre okay for current actual
saying Marvel DC actually whatever real
superhero for release for current
universe superhero things the thing the
least cringe-worthy sci-fi superhero
movie that I've actually seen is Doctor
Strange
dr. stream and the reason that doesn't
fringe me is that a verb to cringe you
just made it one an active verb I cringe
but like to cringe some you made it an
active ER okay Lauren the reason it
doesn't is because it's all magic
because the premise of the movie is that
none of this is science anyway or as say
supernatural right as Reed Richards
would say on his you know Fantastic Four
comic series he regularly would say
I actually know the comic series well
that is the only real smart okay the
cinematic universe stuff it's just all
well in icing on a cake elevates in
Atomics we know what a cannon actually
comes from yes he acknowledges he's like
the greatest scientist in the world
right but he says I acknowledge that
science that magic is a science I do not
yet understand he did say that what's
right yes and so as a result so the
Princess Bubblegum by the way I'm sorry
yeah well it's not a movie it's a series
Oh called adventure time oh yes that the
one what they don't have el bote she
says is basically science magic is just
science unexplained see Clark said right
yes any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from science Oh
from Jim magic from sorry no zany
indistinguishable any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic
yes no I don't mean to boast okay you
can line up for autographs later okay
but I have a cameo in sharknado 6
excellent and I lay Merlin I can't tell
you
I play Merlin look this is the the the
the plot line takes you back to medieval
times well I play Merlin there's a time
work that opens in the vortex of course
there okay I mean we're the Sharks as
they go through the vortex they end up
crossbreeding in this vortex with
dragons as we have shark dragon tornados
back then there was shark dragon nato's
and I play Merlin performing actual
science that everyone thinks is magic
because you're still a science God I'm a
scientist and that was I was true to my
my roots now you didn't realize that you
can say no to these projects we gotta
bring this segment to a close love's
great question yeah I've had fun with
that one yeah when we come back more on
Startalk where we're talking about the
science of
diction can be returned if you like
science fiction and who doesn't like
science fiction you've probably seen
sci-fi fandom communities while
curiosity stream has an excellent
documentary about the subculture of
female fans in phenomenon you will
follow a woman behind a group of
dedicated fans to John Shepard from
Stargate Atlantis she is on her quest to
meet the actor behind the character
watch as she meets up with other fellow
fan girls and see if she gets a chance
to meet the man of her TV dreams they
also get into the economics of fandom
and you'll be amazed with how much money
is spent on these things
subscribe to curiosity stream now to
watch it's just $2.99 per month and for
Startalk fans the first 31 days are
completely free if you sign up at
curiosity stream comm slash Startalk and
use promo code Startalk
you'll get unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries and nonfiction
series with curiosity stream sign up now
we're back on Startalk cosmic queries
the science of poverty and we have
decided with the help of Charles Liu my
friend and colleague and resident expert
what's how would we call geek geek spurt
east expertise yes yes he's our resident
geek and cheats there it is that these
are things you might watch while eating
popcorn mmm pop fiction made in your
science oven by the way I think popcorn
is one of the most extraordinary foods
ever right how many things do you say
gee I want to turn that inside out right
and then and they ate it just every cow
I see okay all right technically you're
kind of doing that but just if you look
at a corner kernel in one instant and
then the next instant it's completely
inside out yeah and if you didn't tell
someone what had just happened they
would think it's two completely
different foods let's say and that is
that you're absolutely that's my only
point there's nobody who could look at a
kernel in and look at a popcorn right
like flourished right and say oh those
that came from that and was
specifically designed by nature to be
absorbent of butter okay so it's the
perfect food it is and almost no
calories oh yes all air so you gotta
load up the butter calories otherwise
you know what are you doing yeah I tried
eating air-popped popcorn without butter
it's like what am i doing why I like it
no the question is you know does it Oh
Tony first young generation thing it
can you put this particular food into a
taco shell and eat it actually taco as a
ver special if you put a sauce on did
you know what else styrofoam also okay
now how somebody knows that the edible
kind not know I got the polystyrenes you
mean the the the starch yeah but a
starch basis Oh like don't kill you but
they're not really but you should put
them in the toilet they just dissolve
right there's I'm to disintegrate right
do they taco and turns out they do yeah
the same is true with popcorn is
dissolving the same thing as
disintegrate I don't think so
they just dissolve in mortar but does
dissolution is a form of disintegrate
I'll give it to you there you go okay
okay nicely done I'd say these guys make
even eating a taco that much more
excited is the joy of the geek averse
Chuck how would you know in advance if
you're a three-year-old whether you're
eating the polystyrene looking court
looking corn or the starch looking corn
I have the answer that when you don't
end up in the hospital okay the right
one degrades give us another question
alright here we go let's get back to our
queries that come from all over the
Internet this is Bellamy Ronnie Bellamy
Ronnie says hey Bella it's actually all
it's Donny one Bellamy Ronnie is from
there yeah Bella Mariani
Omar eonni
cuz belém more ani is like a beautiful
[ __ ] right however more Ronnie is
Swahili for warrior as well so look let
me out with the bellow on it alright
what do you hear we go
hey Chuck will it one day be possible
for entire societies to disguise
themselves in plain sight as Wakanda did
in the Marvel Universe how close are we
to developing invisibility technology so
let's get the top presentations of that
so you have the cloaking device on Star
Trek yeah yeah and also one of the James
Bond movies with Daniel Craig I forgot
which one it was called but it has
something called adaptive camouflage so
you could Park it and whatever it was in
front of it would bring that pattern to
the car
you'd walk by it and he just thought you
were looking at a normal scene right so
there's that there was also cloaking in
chicken little okay excuse me is my
cinematic repertoire too large for you
I'd probably sky is falling was not a
real sky there were hexagonal tiles that
the aliens had put over the earth and
the tile is an exact image of what is
behind it right and when a tile fell
down it fell to the ground and Chicken
Little looked at it and touched it and
it immediately became the floorboards
and it put it on a table it became the
table and so there's five minutes of
this movie doing experiments with the
hexagonal tile so basically it's
cloaking by not becoming invisible but
by becoming what is behind flies it with
camouflage Norfolk camouflage or pretend
one kind of invisibility sure and then
you have what else don't forget
unnoticeable that's good
Harry Potter words today that the cover
I can't take credit for okay so the
cloak the cloak and Harry the cloak and
Harry Potter you have the Invisible
Woman Fantastic Four okay as well as the
who the Incredibles the original
Invisible Man
so what gets me is just because he's
invisible shouldn't automatically mean
he can walk through walls
now why should it ever win that at all
yes of course he did
HG Wells Invisible Man didn't walk - no
no no no I'm talking about how the guy
who was wrapped in a thing and they
unwrapped it and he was invisible yeah
he couldn't walk the walk he couldn't
walk - Walter I'm sure not the original
young his problem was also he had to I
know I'm confusing I'm confusing with
ghosts well why isn't he ghost yeah why
can you walk the walls would not fall
into the basement leave that out right
right yeah that's your wife the floor
holding you up but you can walk off
interesting doesn't make any sense
okay so well so we have a visible woman
invisible woman yet the Harry Potter
thing we Star Trek Rises and then you
have the entire city being clothed right
yes the answer at the moment is no I'm
guessing we can't do a Chuck can we
cloak a whole city no no now at the
moment the answer is that we can seem to
be able to bend light around objects in
such a way that the object would not be
visible to someone looking at it because
all they'd see is the background and you
don't even know the light is bending now
you just see the direction the light
comes from at the last point of contact
so though I can do a full 360 360 180
doesn't matter right and you look at if
all the light coherently comes around
the object right again you've rendered
it invisible that is at this moment only
doable in the laboratory under very
extreme conditions and sort of at the
subatomic level okay however Charles but
I thought I thought I thought DARPA was
working on a cloak like that is that it
is that with okay I'm not authorized to
speak any further on so metrology here's
a problem can you further the city is
sitting on the ground yes you can't
bring light from behind the city around
it right so
so that technology wouldn't work to hide
a city right would only hide objects in
front of other things well in this
makanda they had it was a dome that
covered the city as well right there was
some kind of like forced dome net then
cloaked the city right the dome in that
case was really just almost a mirror in
a sense it projected upon itself Oh
astral images of okay so Jim disappear
it's just it's just a suggestion system
rejection screen and then you had to get
through it and then you saw all the
marvelous technicians right that we can
do we're projecting movies on disguise
great person are we you don't got me
about what Condor how is it that down
into town this is with all this
technology and all this man and all this
stuff they're still selling woven
baskets in the street that's what's up
with that I believe it's very simple
well because they realized they
essentially have infinite wealth and
infinite technology yeah what makes them
happy it's not the toy assets I would
much rather like make a basket you can
draw on this Bassman like you know point
my finger and I have a sort of virtual
basket made of vibranium that's gonna
you know problem I want to made of
vibranium yes what I want I would
appreciate that too if they were
artistic and beautiful no I haven't ate
it I want a bowl I want an actual bowl I
don't want a basket I think I think
that's a it shows a very interesting
utopia actually anyway it was song
there's a hole in the bucket dear Liza
dear Liza
the solution to that is to repair it
with straw that's right okay I'm
thinking why would you straw hold war
I'm just thinking that when I heard that
so it's woven tightly enough that's
right yeah you think so there are many
water proof straw things that the people
before using them I was just thinking is
there any other way you can plug this
hole weld I'm thinking technology
science
let's get straw okay there's a straws
right there as if you got to do the wood
you got a hammer it down or you okay I
just thought they would have a more
permanent solution than just straw
right and there's a hole in the bucket
dear Liza dear life Oh Georgie wanted
was to carry a little water from here to
there why like bring out vibranium for
that and then they said how will I cut
the straw and they say with an axe
no no that's nice either why do you have
to you know yeah I think that the
original song has ax ax yeah go over
kill for straw I think that's I'm saying
the whole song didn't make sense I
stopped listening to it okay what were
you saying Chuck let's bid on
invisibility you go the next quest last
bit is that I think that when we think
about invisibility we want to be able to
take it with us the motion of being
invisible is more important than just
being able to render something not
visible for me in a static plots like
plots and this is the value that Harry
Potter had that's right right and you go
wherever the cloaking cloak is and so
that's really the most important thing
right now then technology is not just to
make something not visible but to make
something not visible as it moves around
to everybody come every point from every
and in fact the lab experiments you're
describing it is only invisible from one
direction one exact direction right
right because the optics only conspire
for that point of view not from the side
yeah that's where we start yeah okay
we'll start there
all right there you know by the way one
other thing militaristically
invisibility just means you're not
reflecting a radar signal rack which we
already have that solid elf so that is a
kind of invisibility that accomplishes
what the Star Trek stealth things were
doing but in a militaristic sense so
yeah all right here we go no the DARPA
project that was by the way stealth was
a d'Arthur I think so yeah we can verify
that we got top crack researchers here
yeah yeah
Defense Advanced Research Projects
there's any other it was not lucky yeah
I dunno it was lucky but are there any
other technological applications for
stealth technology that's redundant but
are there any other applications for
stealth technology outside of absorbing
radar that that might that we might find
in life well sure
well it's not just absorbing radar
absorbed all of it electromagnetic right
rays so whatever might be you only think
you're shooting at it right right and
also there but not all
because some of it has to do with the
shape of the plane - everything else - -
[ __ ] yeah that causes it to roll over
it's the material the shape right um the
the b-2 bomber which looks like a bit
you know bat plane the shape it's
because when the radar signal does
reflect it doesn't reflect back to the
direction they were sent from so it
doesn't reflect it deflected see flex
reflex and there are multiple
reflections within the physical body you
don't want any of them going back to
where - they now have stealth Navy ships
and you look at their shape is like oh
that's a funky kana yeah I see in them
right yeah they're very cool yeah and
then and the masks have certain shapes
just to minimize and reduce the radar
cross-section yeah
so you see it's just like oh it's a it's
a it's a lost whale and it's just like
why is that lost whale shooting the
torpedo cool all right now here we go
this is you solos Lopez first name
useful useful okay yeah or Laurie yussle
Jesse or Jesse uh Mitchell was the name
of the character hustle character in the
in dune by Frank Herbert it was the
nickname given by the Fremen
to Paul Atreides you're too good I'm
telling you man we are unworthy yes we
are unwell I saw the movie the book was
too thick for me to read Oh ladies I say
I didn't read the book in a movie was
too damn long what I like what they have
their language translator where they
it's just thing you put in front and you
speak and out the other side
but now our iPhones do that so I know
yeah all right here we go this is what
useful or useful
Lopez says this is specifically for you
Neal but I'd like to know what Chuck
thinks about the answer should be so a
couple episodes back there was a
reference to the bat-signal and a guess
jokingly mentioned that Neal should have
a meal signal I'm sure is it dr. Tyson
what would your Neal signal in the night
sky be oh that's easy
yeah yeah we already have one of these
there's a there's a web page on Amazon
that sells sanctioned t-shirts right
that are designed by fans but inspired
by my work or my words or my image okay
but it's all sanctioned and the fans get
a fee and everything everybody's happy
and one of them is just simply a
silhouette of my hairline right and a
mustache that's it that's the Neal
signal and ice and that's that's kind of
me right guys I got this sort of widow's
be that okay right you marry Eddie
Munster your head nobody much came to a
point right I know yours is natural
though yeah yeah yeah and so so it's a
and I think when I see that I think of
myself abstracted so then you know what
you want a simple iconography grab that
signal so the Neal signal in case you
get stuck in an argument with a flat
earther and you need help
you just stand on the hairline and the
mustache and dr. Tyson will not show up
to your house so but he'll solve the
argument for you yeah that's cool man
yeah all right Chuck what would you
think it would be I think it would be a
ball in a box the iconic structure of
the Hayden Planetarium see your
silhouette is great but it's a little
too detailed but we should have a little
bit of clouds and you look like Bozo the
Clown yeah you're right
you have to have Spacek shapes that are
immediately recognizable and when we
look if we do that so it's it's because
the Rose Center for Earth and space is a
glass cube yeah and a ball inside
containing the Hayden Planetarium the
rest that iconography would mean if I'm
not available we get some of our other
staff there you go tremendous just say
you need an astrophysicists to help
settle your argument it didn't have to
be me I don't have unique knowledge in
this world now now I'm going back to the
hairline and the mustache as you know
somebody's just like let's call Neil and
they put up the ball in the box right
and all of a sudden like you know just
some intern shows
we got badass interns let me just say
this is true right now all right but I
like the ball in the box very very very
thought right I check what's the next
question okay here we go this is Daniel
J Leigh and he says this is for Chuck
and Neil what superpower would you like
to have that could be theoretically
enabled by gene editing very x-man yeah
I'm that one I have an answer Chuck do
you have an answer I do
we don't have time to give it a take a
break and when we come back Chuck and I
will argue about what genes we will edit
to try to give some kind of superhero
you choose superpowers oh and Startalk
returns this episode of star talk is
brought to you by curiosity stream
Startalk you're back Tyson here Chuck
Lou here Chuck nice there Charlie Chuck
nice you tweet don't you occasionally
Chuck blue blue how are you yeah it's
good Charles Lou's already taken so oh
it's too bad well no it's actually
better it reminds me of my college roots
okay and and you are at Chuck nice
common Chuck nice comment I name and
what I do you actually have to tell
people your comic well you know he's a
comedian right now by the way it was
originally Chuck nice black comic but I
figured okay one of them they'll figure
it out
it also has another he also has another
Twitter handle that he doesn't publicize
so much as at Chuck nice and go-go
dancer that was just for you I'm so
sorry
all right so read this question again
okay right before we went to the break
Daniel J Leigh asked a great question
for Neil and Charles what superpower
would you like to have that could be
theoretically enabled by gene editing Oh
Charles you
I would say and I know this might seem a
little goofy but with gene-editing the
best thing that I could hope for for
myself is that my jeans make it so that
I will stay as mentally and physically
in perfect health as long as I want it's
not a superpower it is immortality but
it's healthy immortality and somehow is
somebody's in distress and you go help
them yes I am he's like worse I'm gonna
stand here and watch you watch you die
if I am immortal then I will have the
opportunity to learn all the medical
technology all of the information over
the centuries in the millennia and that
way I will be able to help people not by
being some crazy guy in a costume
medical acknowledge over the centuries
includes like bloodletting yeah and this
sort of thing well and it depends on
whether that bloodletting is worth
keeping or not okay but for example
these days medical people actually use
leeches ya know get rid of matome us get
rid of bad blood that's right so I just
came at OMA I want I want to make it so
that I have great value to society
without my having to stand out as some
sort of a beacon or a flag post does
that make sense
so I thought is a chart I think it's a
trim minute Charles no one's making a
movie about that oh well there was the
fountain it's the man who was the man of
youth starring a huge Ackman and Rachel
a huge Ackman yeah that's the brother of
Hugh Jackman yeah Neil's what was yours
me so Charles is so going to live
forever I've thought about this actually
and if gene editing is what is allowed
because the x-men stuff is extreme yeah
you're not gonna do jeans and Spitfire
that's not gonna happen but what you're
allowed to do is ask the animal kingdom
what are the things that are exhibited
in all the animals of the world because
we all have DNA in common and I'm going
to say give me some of that okay animal
man so what I would do is I'd say give
me jeans that a snake has where I can
open my mouth five times bigger than my
head so I can finally eat suck the
sandwich at the deli pastrami sandwich
at the deli okay that's not a superpower
that's just that I want to throw that in
there just okay um snakes can detect in
in infrared okay okay insects can see
deeply in the ultraviolet right which is
why bug zappers work because they're
ultraviolet and they said I gotta go to
the ultraviolet and then they die so I
want to be able to see infrared see
ultraviolet also I want to be able to
gene edit other people so that I can
help regenerate the limbs of veterans
who've lost limbs defending this country
cool and newts can regenerate live
exactly humans can't it is in the genome
of the Tree of Life to regenerate limbs
and so I want to be able to have that to
then impart that in fellow humans and so
that everybody gets their limbs back
that's it for me that's a it's not super
power but it's a power that I think
would be greatly value able to
regenerate limbs that's that's a pretty
good right that's a great power and
again no one's gonna make a movie out of
that but people will take a look don't
make a movie out of my power it's true
but notice that the two of us were
thinking about powers that like don't
like matter they don't like turn us into
like these these godlike creatures right
that do stuff to people but rather that
allow us to be part of the society that
matters because that's sort of in a
sense it's kind of what the impulse of
science is I don't know that yes right
great that's that's what we're thinking
about right right and if there's a way
to think about superpowers maybe that's
the best way to do it we can create the
powers you know we have these folks
going out and fighting cosmic villains
or anything like that but why not take
some of that wonderful technology and
heyou people like in black and had third
for example when the black panthers
sister saves the life of that gentleman
that was working with them you know
their super technology was being used
for good and and used
or a societal benefit that's the well
I'm going with super-strength and
sprouting wings like a beetle so that I
don't have wings all the time because
you know that probably get on my nerves
when I'm trying to sleep
oh you want wings that tuck in or a
natural skill under an exoskeleton pop
out when I want to fly and then
super-strength and by the way I'm not
helping anybody I'm going on a life of
crime so you be a supervillain I'd be a
supervillain
without a doubt and then you guys could
figure out a way to stop me Kafka man
cockroach not a beetle what a nice cough
cockroach oh my gosh
well that was your interpretation excuse
me that was a cockroach wasn't it I
don't know I don't everybody read that
story now I don't believe I have put you
an educated man no I'm not it's an
abstract commentary on the
dehumanization of man okay I'm gonna
read it tonight metamorphosis
metamorphosis it short story I'm sure
yeah I would you read it like ninth
grade right okay I probably read it and
don't even know that I've read it okay
okay all right listen that was
interesting that was interesting all
right oh wait so a guy goes to bed and
he wakes up as a cockroach and and it's
thought oh don't make me
as is any has thoughts about what that
means
no it's kind of it's a meditation of his
family members - yeah it's a meditation
on on the thing right it's an
existential story yeah yeah that
questions what is your life I get it all
right here we go let's go to Vaughn
Murray actually he is a patreon patron
oh okay okay sorry they took this long
to get to your question that wasn't
right all right Vaughn here you go this
is what he says dear Startalk experts
and Chuck
that's cold that was oh well you got to
do that dance treat me like I'm cocked
man all right here we go my friend and I
got into a space discussion about future
starship design sci-fi franchises like
to make use of the simulated gravity on
starships and Space Station's by way of
centrifugal force or synth work which is
a rotation Center in a in in a habitat
section we all know what they are okay
as early as earliest evidence in what
was it 2001 a Space Odyssey right okay
would it be realistic to use this idea
for long-term space travel so
yep-yep-yep point is the point is it was
all this research on the medical effects
of zero-g none of which would be
necessary if our long-term space ships
has rotating habitats and you don't have
to be in there 100% of the time but you
go in there to get your sea legs back
you know and you lift weights you do
whatever your bone density stays so how
fast would I have to spend to to give
you one depends where we are it depends
on the radius R the radius entirely so
you'd have to so the smaller radius the
faster has to spend correct and the
larger the way is the slower you want to
make it as big as possible right and
remember in space since there's no air
resistance why do you have to make it as
big SMO who cares it doesn't matter if
it's small then your inner ear has
issues if it's small if if you are large
relative to the size of the thing but
I'm saying if it's still big relative to
you then the size the size doesn't
matter but it's got to get to that but
I'm sure there's a particular size
that's gonna give you the 1g right no no
you're these eyes any size in fact do
this right ahead take a bucket of water
and swing it fast enough over your head
so that doesn't fall out and that's what
one db0 it could be it could be way take
that back night sorry bad exam you're
right but but I'm just saying that's
what happens on a roller coaster we
though yeah yeah you go to you're
weightless and weightless at the top
right the relevant formula is it
eccentric wait a minute this would work
what this would want is B squared over
no no no watch this would work because
if it is zero G at the top and it's not
falling out right that would be one G if
I were in zero g sure are you lost
I'm sorry so the force up is now
counteracting the force down because
we're doing this experiment in 1g right
no the cancellation in space it would be
one punch
okay so the point is it's not hard to
figure out the speed by the way you
wouldn't even need one so you can do 8.8
G you can get ready for the next planet
you visit Mars is 0.3 30 so you're gonna
have you can change the rotation to get
accustomed to being on Mars it can be a
very fun interesting exercise equation
is the centripetal acceleration equals
velocity squared divided by the radius
of rotation okay
so all you do is measure how how far it
is and by the way I did the calculation
for the rotating section in 2001 and
they rotated that three times too fast
yes so people were really bulking up
here's a thing okay they surely knew
what speed it would have to be to be 1g
right it was already rotating slowly
right so it was well it was too boring
for the camera lately but still doing
something so this rate where they match
the rotation of the shuttle to go into
the station
that's 3G right and I said to myself if
you slow this down by a factor of three
you're not doing everything three
whatever the number is you're you had a
terrible boring shot it's a slow boring
move right so I gave it to him yeah gave
it to him all right yeah I just thought
that they were trying to get some s no
resistance working you know how they
were heading to the moon that's cool all
right next question
alright that was actually a really cool
question all right even though all right
here we go Oh Greg Vaughn
we went from Vaughan Murray to Greg
Vaughan coming to us from Instagram
this oh wait one other thing sorry
before we get back sorry to the G yeah
yeah so if you don't have rotating
sections then you need to invent
something that shuts off gravity right
and we know of no such thing okay we're
not even close to knowing so someone
that so in any sci-fi film where they go
enact artificial gravity it's just in
other words they're saying enact the BS
turn on the BS so that we don't float
around now I don't mean to boast captain
the BS is not working I don't mean to
boats go ahead but I had a cameo in Ice
Age 5 all right not a boast grad oh that
that little that little squirrel list if
a squirrel chipmunky thing right
he's on a ship there's a scene it's like
a throwaway scene it's not relevant to
what's going on down on earth but he
accidentally hits the gravity changer
knob he's just accidentally doing stuff
right and there's like a seamers like 20
G and he's flat on the ground and he
can't he lifted up his top jaw and he
can't I mean they're very creative about
how it would be in the height and as you
changed the G's but any of you want to
say that's for yeah so guys we've got
only one minute left Chuck you got a
fast one okay got a fast one Greg Vaughn
wants to know this is there a real
quantum realm oh that's a reference to
Ant Man yes it is can you shrink down so
far you have a whole new universe which
like doesn't follow the laws of anything
and get trapped in there for decades and
things like well there is a quantum
realm the question is can you function
as a normal person in a quantum realm
the answer is you can't of course no no
you gotta be like that but the bottom
line is yes there is such a thing as a
quantum realm there is we can actually
do something in it completely different
story
so the tompkins in Wonderland series do
you know the Tompkins in Wonderland yeah
written by George Gamow so George Gamow
are wrote a series of famous physicists
look at mid-century 20 century house it
says figure out the theoretical
underpinnings of the Big Bang Theory
okay yes yes all right
made the first prediction of the Cosmic
Microwave Background and he said of b-52
and it turned out to be three degrees
the idiot George is rolling in his grave
way to go okay
so anyhow the so he had a series of
stories where he changed the physical
constants of nature in those stories so
in one of them the speed of light was 60
miles an hour
Wow he you are driving down the street
and then he describes how things changed
that's nobody can change Planck's
constant and so then as you walk him
round the quantum realm changes so you
walk through a door and you diffract
walking through a door all the things
that happened to particles great happen
to you Wow
yeah okay that's cool that's very cool
and so but ant-man I think if they had
to make up a bunch of stuff in order to
to let that story roll but I'm glad they
use the word quantum yeah and they
almost use it right
almost baby just right enough to get you
to go see the movie exactly it shows
that they have some concern for this and
more broadly the Marvel Universe as we
know many of those superheroes were once
scientists correct yeah dr. banner even
Spiderman it was in his science class
well they are they all screw themselves
up while they're doing an experiment
that goes horribly I'm just saying that
science matters there in ways that it
doesn't seem to matter in the DC
Universe okay all right we gotta wrap
this up it start to Chuck Charles Lou
thanks as always for being on the show
Chuck nice always a pleasure to my man
you know I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist we are signing
off star talk as always I bid you to
keep looking up thanks to curiosity
stream for supporting this episode of
Startalk are you a sci-fi fanatic then
you got a watch fan on and on on
curiosity stream they look at the
legions of women that make up a huge
subculture in the sci-fi fandom
community learn about a journey to meet
a TV hero the friendships made along the
way and the astronomical amount of money
spent to fuel fandoms
you can watch it for just $2.99 per
month and if you go to curiosity stream
comm slash Startalk and use code
Startalk your first 31 days are free go
there right now with over 2400
documentary features and series to enjoy
it is a great deal
you